Let's specify the behavior
of our enemies.
Each enemy will be associated with
a particular platform, and will
patrol the top of that platform, turning
around when it reaches one of the ends.
Like that.
The enemies also seem to be floating
on some kind of zero gravity, so
we'll have them bob up and
down as they move.
Finally, we need to determine how
to make the enemies dangerous.
Now one option would be to have
GigaGal have a health meter, and
then subtract from that health
every time she hits an enemy.
I think it's more interesting though
if instead, every time GigaGal touches
an enemy she gets flung backwards,
possibly falling to her certain doom.